Hey, welcome back to 40 Days of Holiness.
Oh my goodness, what an epic journey we have been on
together. 40 days of looking into the word of God,
building a theology of what holiness means and what God can do in us.
He can do something more with sin than just forgive it.
He can break its power in our life. And I rejoice in
you being with me and what we've discovered and learned together.
I hope that it's been helpful and that it has launched you
well on a lifelong pursuit of holiness in
your life. Now, I want to close with this story
from C.S. Lewis. I love "The Chronicles of
Narnia." And in book number three of "The Chronicles of Narnia,"
it's a book called "The Voyage of the Dawn Treader." There's a young man
named Eustace Clarence Scrubb, and C.S.
Lewis says, "And he almost deserved it."
He was a young man who was bitter and
whiny and foolish and
cranky and self-important and all sorts of things.
And C.S. Lewis talks about the journey.
He went into Narnia against his own will and winds up on a boat journeying
across the ocean out to the edge of the world in the
land of Narnia.
As they traveled, they came to an island, and on this island, Eustace
slipped away to get away from work and away from the other people, and
he found a treasure hoard, a cave full
of gold. And when he found that cave full of gold, he
was amazed and shocked. He didn't know because he hadn't read the right kind
of books, C.S. Lewis said. He didn't know that
dragons collect
gold and that this dragon,
his hoard was
bewitched.
And he said, "As he sat and thought dragon-y thoughts in his heart,
he dozed off and went to sleep.
When he awoke, he had been changed into a dragon."
He was first very scared and afraid, and he didn't know how to
change. And finally, as the story goes
and takes a winding path, he tries to fix
his dragon-y self.
He tries different things. Nothing works.
Finally, one night as he's sleeping, as great hot
tears spill from his eyes,
he awakens and sees the great lion, Aslan.
And the great lion, he looks him in the eyes and he said, "In a
moment, I knew he wanted me to follow him."
So he began to follow the great lion.
The lion, Aslan, took him up a mountain to a place
where there was a pool of water.
He said, "I went up to the pool and I looked into the pool and saw my
reflection,
and I wept because of the reflection that I saw."
And then he said,
"After I saw my reflection,
I looked at the lion, and I realized he wanted
me to swim and to bathe
myself in the water." But he said, "Won't you need to
undress first?" And I realized he thought, "Oh, a
dragon can molt." And so he began to scratch, and he said, "I saw a layer
of skin come off," and, "Oh," he said, "it felt good to see it go."
But he said there was another layer of skin underneath it.
And he said, "I tried again, and I took off another layer.
And that felt good to see that one go, too.
But there was another layer of skin underneath it."
And then he said, "The lion asked if I wanted his
help."
And he said,
"I laid myself down,
and the lion bared his claws
and dug into my dragon-y self.
It seemed as if the claws would go to the very heart of
Eustace."
And he began to tear great chunks, and he said, "It
hurt like everything."
And then he said, "Then he tossed me into the pool,
and it smarted terribly for a moment and then began to
feel deliciously cool."
Here's my heart for you as you wrap up all of this.
I want you to know and understand
that there is a Jesus, that if you'll follow him,
he'll take you to a place and you'll see yourself
and you'll realize, oh,
this isn't good.
The dragon-y thoughts. And you'll try, and you'll
labor and try to do better and grit your teeth and turn over a new leaf and make
a New Year's resolution.
And it won't work.
But if you'll let King Jesus, the Lion of the tribe of Judah,
bare his claws and sink them to your heart
and tear off that which is unlike him
and get down to the place where all that is not like Christ has
been taken away,
and all that is left is like Jesus.
That's what holiness means.
That's what it means.
Now, I know
that's not scripture.
But it's a beautiful truth.
It captures,
as C.S. Lewis says, the true myth, the story that
God is telling. And God wants to do that in your life.
Won't you let the claws of the lion set you free?
And then walk in that and be a changed man, a
changed woman. May God bless you. May God increase and
grow your holiness until as you pursue and chase after
it, the doors of heaven swing open, and you walk into the
presence of the holiness, the source of it
all, and see him and unafraid. Because after all, the scripture does
say, "Who shall ascend up into the hill of the Lord?
The one that had clean hands and a pure heart."
May God bless you. I started to say, you are dismissed, because I'm a
pastor. I'm so used to saying that at the end of services.
God bless you. Thank you for being here at 40 Days of Holiness.
If you want more information and more
resources beyond this, I've got a page in your workbook.
If you don't have a workbook, you can go get one at 40daysofholiness.com.
And I hope this entire thing is a blessing to you.
If you chase all of that down, there will be a resource page on
the end of that workbook that will tell you more
next steps that you can take in your discipleship and
your walk with the Lord. May God bless you and be with you and give you
peace.